schon seit zwei jahren stecken wir
offensichtlich tief in der sperma krise
laut einer großen studie hat die
spermienanzahl von männern aus den
westlichen industrienationen seit den
70er jahren um mehr als die hälfte
abgenommen in anderen teilen der welt
dagegen gibt es diesen trend nicht was
ist also los mit unserer fruchtbarkeit
klicks um science-fiction
hier geht's täglich faszinierende songs
videos abonniert den kann da nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
in den letzten 40 jahren produzieren die
männer in den industrienationen immer
weniger sperma und der rückgang ist
nicht ohne
laut der umfangreichen analyse eines
israelischen forschungsteams ist die
spermien konzentration im zeitraum von
1973 bis 2011 um mehr als die hälfte
gesunken genau genommen um 52 4% pro
samenerguss sind das laut der studie
sogar knapp 60 prozent weniger als noch
vor 40 jahren das team aus israel hatte
für dieses ergebnis aus dem jahr 2017
und 185 studien ausgewertet dann
wirklich alarmierendes ergebnis dass
zudem auch noch eine überraschung bereit
hält denn offensichtlich gibt es diesen
trend nur in den westlichen
industrienationen
die studie zeigt dass männer in europa
nordamerika australien und neuseeland
betroffen sind die männer in asien
afrika oder südamerika dagegen haben
dieses problem offensichtlich nicht doch
die antwort auf die entscheidende frage
liefert die studie nicht was genau sind
die ursachen des spermien rückgangs
fachleute gehen davon aus dass dabei
verschiedene faktoren eine rolle spielen
könnten männerkörper sind tatsächlich in
der lage die spermienzahl zu modulieren
also quasi zu verändern
die beiden hirnareale namens
hypothalamus und hypophyse sind dafür
zuständig und legen aufgrund
verschiedener parameter fest wie viele
spermien produziert werden sollen
faktoren wie übergewicht stress oder
krankheit können dazu führen dass die
spermien menge verringert wird
eine wichtige rolle dabei spielt auch
wie häufig ein manipuliert denn bis die
neben hohen komplett mit spermien
gefüllt sind vergehen sieben tage
wenn dieser speicher aber oft gelehrt
wird befinden sich im erkrath deutlich
weniger spermien als wenn dies nicht so
regelmäßig passiert manche experten und
expertinnen gehen davon aus dass männer
in den westlichen industrienationen
einfach heutzutage häufiger ejakulieren
also als noch vor 40 jahren die gründe
dafür könnten möglicherweise darin
liegen dass er sexuell freier sind die
kirche weniger einfluss hat und es mehr
pornografie gibt als noch vor einigen
jahrzehnten und sie ist über das
internet vor allen dingen leichter zu
kriegen ist könnte es also sein
das wäre gar keine sperma krise haben
und die heutige spermienanzahl einfach
derjenigen eines regelmäßig
regulierenden mannes also die menge dem
entspricht manche experten und
expertinnen sehen dies tatsächlich als
eine erklärung fest steht jedenfalls die
studie aus israel sagt nichts darüber
aus ob die spermien beispielsweise in
ihrer beweglichkeit eingeschränkt sind
auch morphologische veränderungen also
veränderungen in ihrer form sind in der
analyse außer acht gelassen worden beide
faktoren sind aber entscheidend ob ein
spermium auf natürlichem wege eine
eizelle erreicht somit können auf
grundlage der israelischen studie
keinerlei aussagen über die
fruchtbarkeit getroffen werden denn
weniger spermien bedeutet keinesfalls
automatisch auch eine geringere
fruchtbarkeit probleme mit der
fortpflanzung kann es laut angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu geben
wenn die grenze von 15 millionen
spermien pro milliliter ejakulat
unterschritten wird durchschnittlich
verfügen die männer hier bei uns aber
noch über rund 47 millionen spermien je
milliliter ejakulat dennoch die abnahme
der spermienzahl steht wohl nicht zur
diskussion
dabei ist laut der fachleute aber zu
berücksichtigen dass vor allem die
datenlage aus früheren jahrzehnten
eventuell fehlerhaft sein könnte auch
der vergleich von messungen aus
unterschiedlichen laboren kann zu
fehlern führen dennoch sind
forschungsteams weltweit dabei die
ursache für die spermien abnahme endlich
detailliert zu ergründen
doch das ist alles andere als einfach
diskutiert werden immer wieder
unterschiedliche faktoren nicht nur die
acetylsalicylsäure in schmerzmitteln
sondern auch der missbrauch von hormon
für den aufbau von muskeln sowie das
handy in der hosentasche stehen im
verdacht wissenschaftlich erwiesen ist
jedoch eine sache
ganz eindeutig nur die rauchen wirkt
sich äußerst ungünstig auf die
spermienanzahl aus das robert koch
institut weist zudem darauf hin dass es
in den letzten 50 jahren immer mehr
patienten mit hodenkrebs gegeben hat und
das in einem sehr jungen alter zwischen
25 und 45 jahren manche expertinnen und
experten vermuten dass kommerziell
eingesetzte chemikalien zu der
abnehmenden spermien menge führen doch
für diese these gibt es noch keinerlei
handfesten beweise klar ist aber dass
umwelthormone in der fachsprache auch
als endokrine disruptoren bezeichnet die
spermienqualität beeinflussen und zwar
negativ im menschlichen körper führen
sie zur veränderung des hormonsystems
einige studien zeigen dass diese
umwelthormone schon in kleinsten mengen
die spermienqualität beeinträchtigen
ziemlich bekannt ist der weichmacher de
hp in plastikprodukten der über die
nahrung in den menschlichen körper
gelangen kann oder aber pcb 153 das vor
allem in fettigen lebensmitteln steckt
seit 2015 darf de hp deswegen in der eu
nur mit einer speziellen zulassung
verwendet werden doch wie kann es sein
dass männer in asien und afrika nicht
betroffen sind denn auch dort kommen die
menschen mit solchen umwelthormonen in
kontakt vielleicht sogar noch mehr als
die menschen in der westlichen welt eine
mögliche erklärung könnte sein dass in
asien und afrika diesbezüglich kaum
daten erhoben werden
aber wer soll sich das aber in den
kommenden jahren ändern auch zu
möglichen ursachen für die sperma krise
steht die forschung noch am anfang
trotzdem steht fest dass unsere
lebensgewohnheiten nicht unwichtig sind
sport und der verzicht auf zigaretten
und alkohol wirken sich nämlich sehr
positiv auf die qualität der spermien
aus und somit auch auf die fruchtbarkeit
und natürlich das mit dem sex und dann
wissen wir eigentlich gar nichts denn
meistens wird bei umfragen zu dem thema
gelogen dass sich die balken biegen aber
vielleicht ist das der ja ein grund für
den spermien rückgang eben der sex trend
hat sich verdreifacht 6 und technologie
anklicken anschauen und klicks um
abonnieren weiß es noch nicht getan
haben sollte bis dann dran